on va tenter remis ses missions avec
d'abord le questionnaire qu'en face il
fait repérer votre mot préféré jean
favier l'horizon pirro mehanna le mot
que tu détestes
je crois que c'était idolâtrie la guerre
car bien on met votre drogue favori
wagner château petrus le son le bruit
que que tu aimes
ouais c'est plutôt le son d'une paire de
draps sous un lit à baldaquin par un
soir de nuit pluvieuse
ah bon mois plus tôt le bruit des vagues
et le son le bruit que vous détestez et
notre cycle est dont on a enlevé le
silencieux - c'est le le rire du saumon
qui viennent casser la ligne de makala
mouline jurons gros mot blasphème
favoris au ça ça doit être moi c'est un
peu héréditaire depuis le grand père mon
père c'est toujours moi moi ça marche et
je continue aussi s'est il disait quand
il était vraiment quoi la volaille de
dieu volailles de volailles de dieu
joueront gros mots parce que moi j'ai
tout simplement de votre cambronne ya
bien un mouvement pour illustrer un
nouveau billet de banque
un nouveau billet de banque je crois
qu'on a dû oublier thurgovien pts et il
pensait alors là où des gros shows marx
gaucho mars le métier que tu n'aurais
pas aimé faire gardien de cimetière
le métier je n'aurais pas aimé faire
photographe au monde
il doit pas être payés souvent il ya
beaucoup plus de photos maintenant oui
autrefois il y avait pas maintenant il y
en a et la plante l'arbre où l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
chat chez les fabien chardon le chardon
bref boeuf saint-picq pour pas être
emmerdés justement la personne
n'approche pas d'accord bon et si dieu
existe qu'aimerais tu après ta mort
l'entendre te dira tout à fait repérer
voulez vous êtes bon sommelier et
insidieuse disent qu'elles vous riez
vous après votre mort l'entendre vous
dire à vous j'en fais j'espère qu'il me
dira et à ce soir un concert je vous ai
réservé une classe c'est jean sébastien
bach qui joue mais décidément vous
aimait beaucoup la musique
oui bon ah oui vraiment beaucoup et sans
honte oui bah non